Kym's with us in memphis hi Kim how are
you hi how are you David to talk to you
you too what's up in your world my
husband December 24th oh my goodness 45
he had a GBM great boy was a very rapid
decline but I was very happy and honored
to be called his wife and take care of
them in his last moments he died here at
home with us and we held his home
we held his hand and as he took his last
breaths oh wow Christmas Eve all of our
children have that memory wow I'm so
sorry oh at that time our young it was
six he turned seven on January 4th and
we have a 13 and 14 year old my husband
very godly man and he believed in trying
to make sure you know that we were okay
so he worked I stayed at home to tell my
children and died of course he had
insurance at work and he also purchased
private insurance and that I wasn't sure
those who is clear equal death I've ever
seen but not nearly there now you
probably or anyone else but it's small
to many people it's um it's four hundred
four hundred thousand that's very very
start-stop both policies total four
hundred thousand the total both of them
yes the private and the one at work okay
what did he use to make as an income
seventy to eighty three years okay and
do you guys have any debt very little
did we have a
a car he had a he purchased a minivan
for me and then there's a car that's
already paid for how much is owed on the
minivan about 3,500 how much is owed on
your home so we don't have a home we
moved into an apartment when my husband
no you know okay so you don't own a home
currently yeah then you have three
children and you're in the apartment
okay is there any money other than the
four hundred thousand but I don't know
what that is yet I see the pension which
car are you going to keep which what am
I going to keep you don't need to what
will the other one's self or I think
it's a 2000 he bought it
I'm a crew member at work and it was a
2500 driven okay so it's worth a couple
grand yeah okay
all right good news okay well here's a
couple things to think through right
number one I'm so sorry this is an
amazing thing for your young family to
go through number two I'm going to
assign one of our coaches that has been
through our training to walk with you
through this at no charge we don't sell
anything and we don't want anything we
just want to help you okay all right are
you in a good church okay good so you've
got some support around you and
hopefully family as well then what I try
to do is I know if something happened to
Sharon we've been married 34 years and
if something happened to her I wouldn't
be able to breathe for a while
and it this is really really fresh right
now and some some days you do well and
other days you don't and that would be
normal grieving for normal people in
your situation okay mm-hmm so in other
words it's not a really good time to
make big money decisions right now
because no matter who you are me
included and I'm the money guy if I were
in your shoes I wouldn't be thinking
clearly and so a good rule is to try not
to make big decisions if possible and in
the good news is you really don't have
to make any big decisions today you
don't have to be an expert on investing
less than 30 days from the time that
your husband goes to heaven I mean that
you just don't it's okay you're in good
shape
so what what I would tell you to do is
make a couple of little moves and then
the rest of the money I would just sit
on it and cry for a while
number one move is we probably keep one
car sell the other one and pay off the
van okay but that really isn't going to
take much money the other car will sell
for almost enough to pay off the van
right right and then the rest of the
money we're just gonna park it in a
simple CD it doesn't really earn
anything and you're gonna pull just a
little bit off per month to meet your
monthly budget only you set yourself a
really tight monthly budget tighter than
you used to live on probably and live on
that to minimize the amount of this
money that you use before you start
investing it because if you use up a
bunch of it the amount of money it will
make when you start investing it will be
less that make sense in other words if
we spend thirty thousand bucks to live
for the next six months that leaves you
somewhere around three hundred and
seventy but if we spend a hundred
thousand in the next six months that
only leaves you three hundred thousand
to invest to live off the income that it
creates so we want to leave that nest
egg as big as possible so for the future
by but without you know without being
crazy I mean you all need to live but
you got to be aware of what's called
grief spending which is spending
medicate your pain and not behaving that
I haven't received anything yet and I'm
grateful I'm just in prayer about them
yeah that's good just get a prayer is a
good place to be find some peace in the
middle of this and financial peace is
part of the equation and we just start
developing a game plan and so I would
park the money and do as little as
possible now can you all live in that
apartment comfortably for six months
yeah
disability starting in October so they
just converted well they will convert
once they receive the death certificate
the Social Security disability benefits
Edition evidences exactly and and
that'll help to not draw down on the
400,000 to live that'll help you with
your budget
so my recommendation if emotionally
since he passed in that apartment
if emotionally you can stay there I
don't know you got to make that decision
I would make as few decisions as
possible sell one car key point that's a
small decision stay in the apartment for
six months and cry hey mommy cry the
whole six months but I mean get past the
worst part of the grieving and then
start talking about doing some investing
then start talking about this and one of
our coaches will help you Kelly Daniels
going to pick up and we're gonna hook
you up with one of our coaches again at
our expense you will pay nothing this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]